we have as usual a very interesting
panel of people whose BIOS I will not
bother to repeat since you have them in
your program and I don't believe in
unnecessary repetition but I'm sad to
say that the subject of this panel makes
me nostalgic because for about 10 years
between my senior year in college when I
wrote my undergraduate thesis on police
systems in Vietnam and how they related
to counterinsurgency and the publication
of a book that I had my name on called
the irony of Vietnam ten years later I
did a lot of research and work on what
happened in Vietnam and why and so I'm
counting on this panel to tell me why I
haven't seen this movie before Colonel
George okay thank you and good morning
everybody it's important my perspective
I just got back in June of this year
from commanding a Brigade task force I
was in the in the Northeast upward manga
haar Kunar Laghman and nursed and
primarily posh tune area although nurse
Danny's small ethnic group that live up
in in that area had about 6500 people in
our task force between 40 and 50
civilians that at the end from all the
different agencies Department of State
USAID USDA we worked with with all the
different agencies were at algún in
Jalalabad and had a senior civilian
counterpart who you'll hear from later
today Dante Paradiso about the size of
Massachusetts if you rolled it out it
was about the size of Kansas and I guess
that's important because geography does
is important not only for military
operations and how you know the type of
government it's established there
probably the major group in our area was
was hIgG and
you know who see themselves a lot of
times as a political party and have that
discussion back and forth also hick T
and SM TTP Taliban as various groups and
then we could go into into great detail
when we talk about today about the
tribes my paradigm as an Army officer is
is the president decides that
Afghanistan is important to our national
interests then what's what my job is or
our job is is to figure out how to be
successful in that when he gives that
and then and give that back to him so I
believe that I wanted to spell I'm going
to give five myths today and I wanted to
spell the overall myth that Afghanistan
is a lost cause in the way that we are
currently pursuing it so that's what the
five myths that will go and I I really
won't divide I hear a lot of people
talking about political and military and
I think some of the things that we're
doing now with with actually having all
these everybody embedded is that you
really can't divide political and
military and I'm going to give you some
examples of why they're all they they're
basically all interlinked in Afghanistan
okay
myth number one that I'm gonna share
with you is is that we can't or
shouldn't work with the tribes now you
hear this a lot you hear a lot of people
say we can't work with the tribes
because it the tribes are duplicitous
it's too complicated and what I found in
Afghanistan is is that that is that's
just a facet of that society it is the
tribes that control the resources the
timber gems marble they are respected in
that society and and so you you really
can't even the government leaders I know
every time there was a problem anywhere
in our area the first thing that was
suggested was that they were going to
pull together a Jirga and that consisted
of the of the tribal members and where
it got complicated was deciding with
which one blows that you were they were
actually going to invite the xinhua
retried for example was something that
we worked with they are in the south
East portion of manga ha it's about
close to a million strong tribe and they
do control their area they denounce the
Taliban they denounce drugs and the one
thing that they were really focused on
which was a threat at the time to the
government was that they wanted to have
a say in who were the local government
officials and I would argue that that is
and we'll get to the government and
several this the real issue there that
people are rejecting is local government
and by not allowing the tribes to have a
say and some of who is at the local
government is causing problems ok myth
number two is that the quantity of a NSF
trained is the most critical ingredient
and I bring that up and people even read
and in Bob Woodward's most recent book
they talk about numbers or they put four
hundred thousand what's most important
is the quality of the folks that we
train and then also that they are that
they buy into the government project or
the local government one quick example
in Narae which is a district in northern
Kunar we were looking to double the size
of the police force it was about sixty
people and we knew we had to increase it
part of the problem with the police
force was is that there was they were
all from one tribe there was two tribes
that were that dominated that district
plus there were Duggars and coochies
which are the nomadic tribes that live
up into that area by bringing all these
people together and actually working
with them they selected with those with
the other tribes sixty other people to
be in the in the police department the
local police department and so really
what we did is right-sized the police
based on the situation that was on the
ground and they had a lot to do with
political accommodation so it gets back
to the political and military I think
that you can say well just hire some
people actually what's going to be a
part of reconciliation and I think
you're seeing that right now with what
General Petraeus has been doing with the
local tribes is who you hire is very
critical and how they're hired so that
will be part of political accommodation
and reconciliation number three is that
myth
is that reconciliation with the Taliban
is going to stabilize Afghanistan and I
bring that up because the Taliban is not
a monolithic enemy and I it's used often
times as monolithic and we found in our
area although there was Taliban you're
looking at hick and all the other groups
that I mentioned before Jame islami
just all the different groups that are
there that are going to cause us to have
that we're going to be forced as part of
reconciliation and finding solutions is
that we're going to have to work with
these various groups and like I said in
our area was predominantly hIgG about
seventy-five percent if you ask the
people who they what who they aligned
with it was Hague in our area and so I
think that it's the it's going to look a
little bit different based on regions is
how some of this political accommodation
takes place but it's not just the
Taliban okay
myth number four is that kinetic
operations are not part of a large part
of coin we've heard a lot recently
talking about kinetic operations that
they're going that there's too many
kinetic operations that are happening
right now are the focus is on
counterterrorism and and to be truthful
a large it's very large portion of coin
is is kinetic operations that has to be
one thing that you cannot do and we have
run into this problem occasion in
Afghanistan with the locals is when they
would see that we are not dealing with
the enemy somebody who is harassing a
village who is is trying to come in and
implement their own form of justice and
we're not going after those people then
we are seeing seen as weak or in a lot
of cases they would they thought we were
all allowing it to happen so it does
make a big big difference it was a SIB
cast study when people came over I think
it was Sarah Sewall who came over to
Afghanistan last winter and I think one
thing she was surprised to hear was it
actually they were in areas asking us to
do more kinetic operations to take care
of the enemy and
I think that that's a very important
part and then myth number five and this
gets at the government piece is that
because I had read a lot this a lot
about this lately is having Karzai as
president and our partner dooms our
mission and I think that gets back to
the whole government piece I think it's
commonly recognized that that power is
going to have to be devolved some from
the center and it's that's how the
society is going to work in some way
decentralized portion and so I think
reconciliation is going to start to
force some of that really what people
want locally and that's what they're
fighting against is their local
districts of Governors and local police
and the corruption at the local level
that's what they see Kabul is not really
a psychological center of gravity's the
same as what you saw a lot of we saw in
Iraq where people were really focused on
Baghdad they're not as focused on it in
Kabul and so we I think what we we need
to do is really focus on the kind of
building the kind of government that's
going to last over there and and that's
really what counterinsurgency is is a
comprehensive strategy to make sure that
we are not having defeating dismantling
and defeating the Taliban but also then
providing an environment where it's not
going to allow terrorist safe havens so
I really see what's going to you know
rather than a lost cause what's most
likely is that we will maintain a
central government but power will be
devolved some from the center as part of
reconciliation and and political
accommodation now the center will still
control donor funding and and and will
also the Afghan National Army and the an
cop but I do think that Afghanistan is
not a lost cause and that it can work
with and it's going to take some time
with our current strategy Thank You
Austin long thanks I'm going to touch on
a couple of I think macro issues that
affect counterinsurgency I'm I don't
think Afghanistan is a lost cause at all
but I'm I think less sanguine
colonel georgia is about the prospects
so I want to touch on two macro issues
the possibility of potential alternative
strategies and that would be the first
half of my remarks and the second I'm
going to talk at the micro level some
observations from khakhras prophet
Cochran's district and Conda Hart
province where I spend time this past
June just to give you a little bit of
the feel for facts on the ground at
least in one small but an important
segment of the war so you know I think
there are some some myths as well not
just about Afghanistan but about
counterinsurgency generally and I think
one of the most problematic from a
policy standpoint at this point is the
myth of American agency in these
conflicts and I don't mean agency that's
located off chain Bridge Road in
Northern Virginia though it does play a
role
I mean agency and the ability to affect
events on the ground and particularly
people's perceptions on the ground as
well as people's preferences on the
ground so right now I think in certain
segments of the US government
there's an idea that we have a recipe
for what counterinsurgency is and the
recipe worked in Iraq and some version
of it will work in Afghanistan so the
recipe goes something like this
different people will put weight on
different aspects but a sufficient
number of troops in Iraq manifested in
what came to be called the surge there's
similar effort in Afghanistan now to the
right leadership most notably the sort
of Paragon for that as General Petraeus
but there are a variety of other
commanders as well who get who get
thrown in the mix there you're a
charming masters etc and third the right
doctrine and tactics embodied in the
great holy writ that is Field Manual 3 -
24 now as well as some subsidiary
manuals so this combination this recipe
worked in Iraq and now you know it may
it may be ugly there will be some
contestation but it will work in
Afghanistan and I think this is
borderline nonsense what changed in Iraq
had fundamentally to do with Iraqis the
United States was able to aid and assist
in a lot of these efforts and in some
cases to to take advantage of changes
but fundamental
what changed was inside the intro Sunni
Civil War Between al-qaeda and various
other Sunni groups al-qaeda became a
greater threat than the United States or
even the government of Iraq so once that
change happened inside the Sunni
community suddenly things that had not
been possible in 2003-2004 became
possible 2005-2006 nope
chronologically this is before the surge
second things happen inside the intrest
she of civil war that was going on in
Iraq the Maliki government had been
quite weak until finally some decisions
were made about how to confront and deal
with the Mahdi army
one of the main Shia militia groups
which had been fighting against not just
the United States but also other Shia
factions inside Iraq
so once the Maliki government was
empowered and decided along with other
Shia groups to take on the Mahdi army
that changed a big dynamic and finally I
don't put as much weight on this but
other people do there was a realization
among Sunnis particularly around Baghdad
that they were on the losing end of a
civil war anyway so this inter-ethnic or
intersect Aryan civil war came to some
resolution as well the United States was
able to to take certain actions that
took advantage of these changing
dynamics but the fundamental fact is we
caused none of them so it was not this
magic recipe on on three fronts instead
it was right place right time certainly
I give credit to General Petraeus more
troops helped a lot of these things were
important but they did not fundamentally
alter the dynamics so the question we
have to ask ourselves in term of agency
going forward is what dynamics that have
made Afghanistan so troubling over the
past nine years are going to change in
the near term future that is to say the
next one to three years I don't see much
prospect for change on that and I'll
touch on the reasons why next when I
talk about the related concept of
leverage you hear a lot about leverage
in counterinsurgency conflicts I think
in Afghanistan there are two main actors
the United States needs to apply
leverage too unfortunately we have
little prospect of being able to do so
the first is the Karzai government
itself
I disagree somewhat with ambassador
Khalilzad he suggests that it's merely a
matter of talking to one guy sitting in
a room maybe staring at each other
Seoul's a little bit I think that's
nonsense
the cars cars eyes clearly the first
among equals in his government but there
are many other factions but the
fundamental problem the United States
faces with that with that government is
that it has the credible threat to
commit suicide and the United States
cannot cannot abide that we care more
about the stability of Afghanistan and
many in the government do and as long as
that's true
we have no threat to do the things we
could do to apply leverage as that as
the Ambassador mentioned we essentially
pay for everything that the government
does unless we have a credible threat to
cut that off what leverage do we have we
have no credible threat to cut that off
so every time we talk to him yeah that
Karzai he sort of nods his head and goes
about his business because he has he has
no reason to believe we would ever leave
despite what ambassador Khalilzad said
second and I think even more important
there's the relationship with Pakistan
where we have even less leverage the
ambassador was was very diplomatic as
you expect was someone at the rank of
ambassador I'm not so diplomatic
he said the relationship with Pakistan
was complex I think it's more fair to
say that you know dick touched on on
Vietnam we have the relationship with
Pakistan that we would have had with
North Vietnam if 90% of our supplies
were going through North Vietnam into
South Vietnam this is a real problem
because the enemy we are facing in
southern eastern Afghanistan is
primarily supported and has sanctuary in
Pakistan don't be fooled that there are
rogue elements of ISI supporting
different groups in in Afghanistan the
action arm of the Pakistani State inside
of Afghanistan is the Haqqani network
quite a shore a Taliban to a lesser
extent Hague probably least of all but
fundamentally Pakistan is at the root of
all of this you can understand why I
don't hold it against them this is their
backyard they want to have influence but
the reality is unless that changes we're
going to have a very hard time
succeeding in Afghanistan and when 90
percent of your supplies go through that
country the number is coming down thanks
to the northern route but it's still
fundamentally coming through Pakistan
and when you need their help against
al-qaeda and when you are afraid of the
Pakistani state collapsing which i think
is unlikely at this point but it's still
possible particularly if we cut our
support to them because they might lose
control of their nuclear weapons etc
you're going to have a very hard time
getting
bridge over them so I think our leverage
in this situation is extraordinarily
limited absent leverage over those two
major actors in this conflict I'm not
very sanguine about the prospects for
success
so that's the macro-level and why I'm
pessimistic I think we should look I
think Colonel George is absolutely right
when when a military officer is given a
mission he has to try and do the best he
can with it I think we need to rethink
whether counterinsurgency is actually
the best way to achieve the United
States national security goals in
Afghanistan I've been a proponent of
what the Vice President has called the
counterterrorism option I think there
are perhaps other options we can talk
about that QA I won't belabor that point
but I think there are other things that
the United States can do to reach its
fairly modest national security goals
that don't involve this massive
enterprise and the loss of life and
expenditure of treasure that goes with
it
all right briefly on khakhras khakhras
for those of you who don't hang out in
Kandahar is northwest of Kandahar City
it's sort of the hinterland of of
Kandahar but it's important because it's
been one of the main areas where the
Taliban has been able to move through
and use as a staging area for attacks
into more populated parts of the
province along the Arghandab River like
kana har city and like Arghandab
district when I was there this past June
the United States Special Forces had
moved in what's called village stability
platform it used to be termed the local
Defense Initiative or the community
defense initiative this program which I
think is useful in a variety of ways I
think there are others that see it as a
path to more militias but I think it's
actually pretty useful puts a Special
Forces team in this case an Afghan
Special Forces team a US Special Forces
team some Civil Affairs some
psychological operations etc into a
community so they don't live on even you
know certainly don't live on a big base
they don't even live in what's called a
combat outpost this team lived in a
school that the Japanese had built in
2003 that the Taliban had ransacked and
so they moved into this school literally
across the wadi to the to the west was
was a village there was another village
to the north about 700 meters there was
another village to the south about 800
meters so this is about as close as to
the community as you can get the intent
of this program
is to create what's termed a stability
bubble around the village by building a
community defense force and providing
development I think the team that was in
place to do this in khakhras was the
best possible team you could have asked
for the Special Forces team captain on
the American side was the kind of guy
who could walk around any of the
villages in his area of operations and
tell you the life story of everybody who
saw that guys had settled coochy I
really like him even though he has the
weirdest belly I've ever seen on a human
being this guy is a he's an orphan
because his family was killed this way
etc so the best guy you could possibly
ask for unfortunately back to my major
theme of the limits of American agency
the US Special Forces don't run
revs the guy who does is the district
sub governor he's a Popples I not
coincidentally the tribe of Karzai the
Chief of Police was his brother also a
Pappas I you can imagine where the sort
of locus of power was in that district
and it was no great shock to anyone that
most of the insurgents were drawn from
the rival alko's I tried I tried that in
other parts of Kandahar is actually
relatively anti-taliban in this case
though because they were shut out of
essentially all all sources of
government power
they were pretty reluctant to support
the government this isn't a deep shock
so the question was how do you replace
this guy second most of the other
leadership outside of the outside of the
pop was I had fled fled from khakhras
they were all in condo har city
everybody that left was essentially a
sharecropper incidentally what were they
sharecropping opium of course poppy but
it is what it is I missed the harvest by
a couple of weeks it was apparently
quite beautiful before that but the
problem was that there was no real
leadership absent leadership outside of
this Popples I administration there was
going to be a hard time developing this
community defense force people were
actually welcoming the Americans they
appreciated the development a the
Americans were bringing at the local
level rebuilding caresses for irrigation
rebuilding wells etc but no one was
going to stick their neck out and there
were few leaders to sort of provide the
nucleus to do this now
I'll stop I'll stop there but just to
say there are other places even in
Kandahar where this has not been the
case Arghandab district the adjacent
district on the road to kondeh har City
has been quite different there's been a
much larger us effort there and Alec OHS
I tried there has been much more
welcoming of those efforts but the
question is and I'll leave it here is
most of Afghanistan particularly in the
south and east
more like khakhras or is it more like
Arghandab I certainly hope it's more
like Arabic Arghandab but if my fear is
it's much more like rescue Austin a
Wagner alright thanks very much dick
you've told me I got a limit this to 15
minutes which is hard but I'm gonna even
use even less and a lot of time for some
questions we kicked off this session
today with references to the late Albert
Wolf's Tedder and they were saying kind
things about Albert the last dinner I
had with Albert I was insulting him by
telling him he had a large problem
dealing with reality I'm gonna segue
into this by saying one of the things I
want to talk about is looking at
Afghanistan and really dealing with
reality I'm gonna not use any micro
level comments but basically talk about
some macro level elements of the
situation which I think are overriding
and then what some of the stated
objectives are and why I believe they're
either mythical or not simply not
achievable one of the basic numbers is
that the nation of Afghanistan and I've
spent a long time looking at that Toni
Quartus Minh and I did a extremely long
book which is not worth the money
looking at the Soviet operations in
Afghanistan and what went on ever since
but in any event you currently have a
nation where somewhere around 20 and 8
percent of the entire population
couldn't read and write
which means illiteracy is the second
highest and the entire planet and at the
present time although the Ambassador
passed over it a little at the end you
have an economy that's based about 75%
on illicit drugs the only other
component of this economy from a group
that just came back and I met with is
essentially the administration of the US
aid
if you put these things together and we
start looking at the road ahead you know
let's talk a little about we've spent
ten years and fifty two billion dollars
in Afghanistan fine if we look ahead
what has this gotten us and where are we
likely to be under air at any scenario
in another five or ten years no matter
what we do what we surge what we splurge
and what we do with the US military
which I believe are at the moment the
finest that have ever worked on this
planet where are we going to be is it
going to look any different and you can
complain about the Karzai government
which I don't want to do because I don't
think there's anybody better you're
going to find Iran a government there
but in a nation which is essentially
illiterate dependent on illicit drugs
through their economy and essentially is
a mosaic of clans who have no use for a
central government of any kind you're
not going to see anything that's a great
deal different if you ask yourself the
question if the United States had a GNP
there was seventy five percent dependent
prostitution drugs and gambling our
federal government it look like the
soprano family stop complaining about
Karzai or thinking you're going to
change this radically within the next
five or ten years no matter how many
troops you send in here and what you do
at any local level you are not going to
create an economy that is based on the
manufacture of cheap electronics
consumer textiles or anything else other
than the illicit drugs it simply is not
going to happen nor are you going to
change yo you're doing some things at
the margin the world is not binary it's
not either/or you know it's a really a
world of marginal economics and marginal
activities and most of what your here
and here you know we've got schools here
and schools there we're working with
this clan here we're working with that
clan they're fine but are you going to
change the big numbers at a macro level
in the next five or ten years and the
answer is resoundingly no if you back up
and then look at well what are we doing
and why are we there current president
spent some months studying the situation
with his war council almost a year to
the day of today he gave his West Point
speech where he articulated or was
written for him the objectives that he
had for our government going forward in
Afghanistan and you look carefully at
that speech there is nothing in that
speech which is either true in fact or
realizable in reality yeah
not unlike Dick Cheney and George Bush
he and I've got the speech all printed
out if you want me to read it for him
but anyway he basically started out by
saying well we were attacked on 9/11
these guys came from Afghanistan and
we've got to do something there I've got
news they did not that 20 people on 9/11
one got bounced at the airport in Miami
the 19 guys a guy didn't came from Egypt
Saudi Arabia and were trained in Hamburg
Germany they didn't come from
Afghanistan
nor did they come from Iraq as Bush and
Cheney tried to sell us for eight years
wrong he looked at some length at why
Afghanistan was not like Vietnam and if
they could give me another half hour I'd
probably go in and see why I think it is
or is not like it Vietnam but there are
some useful things to see there but we
have to look ahead and see what
objectives are in fact realizable
dealing with the al Qaeda in Afghanistan
does not require 150,000 additional
troops and if you looked at the leaked
cables from Karl Eikenberry back
unfortunately they were leaked and the
Ambassador was unhappy about that but if
you look at what he was saying I
fundamentally agree which is exactly not
what the administration has done if
you've got 120 or 150 al-qaeda guys
floating back and forth the border into
upper Waziristan sending a hundred and
fifty or 200,000 troops into the region
to chase them is not the answer if
you're trying to eliminate the Taliban
as an active political force and I agree
with Austin and the others it's not
mounted not unitary there's at least
five families at Connie's and the others
as an effective force in Afghanistan
that's not going to happen either
it's sort of like punching your pillow
you put your hand in you pull your hand
out pillow pops back that's not going to
happen so we have to look ahead
seriously at what objectives are and not
are not realizable the idea of having a
free honest and not corrupted election
is unmitigated nonsense if you look at
yesterday's New York Times on leaked
stuff we just met the hundred and fifty
million dollars on another election and
it was crooked and there's no evidence
that if we spend another hundred and
fifty million on the next election in
2014 that's not going to be over 2012
the same result it's just not going to
happen when you've that that kind of
nature in the basic society with regard
to counterinsurgency and all sort of you
know wrap up here for a second
Austin I think is basically right there
is great debate over what
counterinsurgency can and cannot do in
any particular situation what the
history shows us and the great deal has
been written counterinsurgency only
works in very specialized circumstances
where there are conditions that are
conducive to its success I don't think
Afghanistan is really one of those cases
what we have going on I believe are some
local situations where US ice F forces
have in fact been able to make life
better for some areas some plans and
working some locals that have had some
success in making life better is this
radically going to change the country
and it's going to change things it will
make a huge difference to u.s. national
security in the next five to ten years I
think absolutely not will it change the
basic nature of government in
Afghanistan and the next five to ten
years probably not so then the question
becomes what is it worth to spend
another 50 or 100 billion dollars of US
funds that really makes an enormous
difference to the security of this
nation and if wrap up for one second if
we look back why are we in Afghanistan
what real objective are we achieving
that makes a fundamental difference to
American security if there's what are
the assumptions going in and like
Vietnam where years later we found out
that the best and the brightest had
simply made some mistakes the domino
theory was essentially not correct we
may in fact be making some basic
mistakes about what in fact a different
kind of Afghanistan makes to the future
of the American Republic and even our
allies and we've got to think seriously
about that and is it worth that kind of
treasure and that many more American and
allied lives but and so I'll sort of
wrap up here and you have any questions
I'd be happy to respond to him in the
time available please line up behind the
microphone if you want to ask questions
I have to say I'm kind of depressed I
wish we'd had a more optimistic member
of the panel we did invite general
McChrystal to speak at the conference
but he had another commitment he does
reportedly get about $75,000 in
appearance these days and we couldn't
quite compete but if there are any in
the audience who have a more optimistic
point of view I'd be especially
interested in letting you jump the queue
and then the question and answer period
please
we're gonna have a whole panel on that I
believe next and Professor fair that's
behind you in line there's the expert on
Pakistan much more than I am but from my
perspective I think it's it's all three
one there are divisions there are real
divisions within the Pakistani security
establishment some are more inclined
towards whatever you want to call it
fundamentalist Islamic vision others are
not but one thing they can agree on is
the other two points you made which are
that they need influence and the more
influence the better and in their
neighbor and second that the more that
they can get proxies to do this the less
they will have to commit their own you
know sort of direct resources and they
can focus more on what is the overriding
obsession in what folks have called the
strategic Enclave inside of Pakistan
which is India right that it's easy
sitting in New York not to realize how
deep that obsession goes but it isn't in
Islamabad it's it's a real obsession and
it's you know you can talk about it
whether it's it's logical or not but it
is a real obsession so I think that you
know for their for their own interests
not because you know they're being bad
people but because they see that their
interest is in doing this the Pakistani
state particularly its security
establishment is playing fundamentally
with the United States they're happy to
help us against some enemies
particularly their own enemies like the
Pakistani Taliban they're
extraordinarily reluctant to help us
with others and I think there's no
better piece of evidence for that than
to look at where the majority of drone
strikes essentially all of the drone
strikes that are allegedly taking place
inside Pakistan happen they happen in an
area where there's a mix of militants
most of whom are opposed to the
Pakistani state how many take place in
Baluchistan where the Amin you reference
the quite Ashura Taliban guada is not in
the federally administered tribal areas
it's in Balochistan right and there's a
reason why no drone strikes take place
there now what some people say is it's
because it's a real province of Pakistan
and not this sort of Wild West
borderland I think there's some truth to
that but the reality is they're
supporting the quite Ashura
why would they let us strike them the
only exception to this is Haqqani and
that's just because the area where
Haqqani is is so mixed in with al-qaida
with Pakistani Taliban with all these
other forces that it would be very
difficult for them to sort of do that
but you could look at where their own
operations are South Waziristan they
were absolutely gung-ho to go into
eventually North Waziristan we're a
little busy were tied down whatever that
that's not an accident right North
Waziristan she's an akane networks home
for 30 years this is not an accident at
all Randy and Abe jump in at any point
on these questions that you want next
as you see it and secondly given that in
the last decades we chose him to
reconstitute from the ground up to major
national security forces were their
transferable lessons from the experience
with the Iraqi natural security forces
to if just to give a preface dierent if
you want a absolute detailed answer with
a gazillion PowerPoint slides and text
oh no not today but you know for your
own mic my colleague Tony Cordesman if
you grab his stuff off the CSI web site
you know you can get infinite colored
PowerPoint slides which has this in
excruciating detail and Austin you
probably wanted to tackle this for a
second what Randy George who actually
yeah I would just and I briefly touched
on that I think we have taken lessons
I've spent a couple of tours in Iraq and
it you do apply a lot of the same
lessons I mean obviously we're learning
from what we're doing one of the points
that I brought out earlier though that I
think you can't neglect is and this gets
back to well the military if they just
build the security forces and then we'll
focus on the political problem will the
whatever the forces they have - a lot of
that is a the political problem as I
mentioned earlier and so if they're
buying into the government and you're
trying to have a certain quality I do
think that those are the most important
pieces to getting a the security forces
built up I do think that we have done a
lot more over the last year or so
with general Caldwell there's been a
real focus on that and a lot of that has
been the resources there's been a lot
more resources that have been focused
and helping to train those but that was
a big that was a big focus of what we
were what we were doing over there so I
do think that the lessons have been
applied I guess one of my big concerns
it was true in a rocket as well a little
more muted now is the politicization and
sort of embedding of these deeper
political and sectarian conflicts in the
security forces in Iraq it was trying to
reintegrate reintegrate who were called
former regime elements people who had
been in the former security
establishment principally Sunnis that
was a hard thing now it's reintegrating
or actually integrating what are called
sons of Iraq sort of folks that had
worked with the United States that as a
paramilitary or quasi military level in
Afghanistan from my perception it's you
know we intervened in a civil war in
2001 I don't know that many people sort
of think of it that way but that's what
we did there was an ongoing civil war
principally between toj expects and
Hazara and the overwhelmingly Pashto and
Taliban we empowered the winners and so
there's a strong Tajik and to a lesser
extent was back on Hazara presence in
Afghan security forces and I think
that's a problem going forward
particularly since some of the best and
most reliable troops are Tajiks
and you're sending them to Pashto areas
this is kind of a problem so that the
Afghan Special Forces team this is the
you know elite of the elite inside the
Afghan security force that's right
they've come from the commando battalion
they're given additional training to
sort of try and bring them up to US
Special Forces standards not a one of
them is a 12-man team not a one of them
was posh to them right the team team
leader was Togiak you know most of them
were from a couple of specific provinces
bagua and Badakhshan and they were good
guys and you know they were they were
pretty awesome but they were clearly not
locals I mean they were more local than
the American special forces team but
that's a that's a problem now to be fair
the sergeant major for all afghan
special forces was there with them
because
was a very serious new deployment and he
was pushed him and he was awesome if we
had a thousand of that dude we would be
doing really well there's not a thousand
Tim there's probably one to ten I don't
know but the point is I worry about that
that division inside
Afghan security forces going forward I
wanted to make one comment I guess
that's because you said you're concerned
about tying in the politics in it and I
guess and I thought he just made the
point that you can't ignore it and I
guess that's what I'm saying you cannot
ignore the fact the ethnicities and the
politics what we're building that's an
important critical ingredient ingredient
to it it's not just building them and
training them it is understanding those
kind of dynamics that we have to do to
move forward in some cases solving that
is the biggest will help us the most I
mean a lot of times that is the
impediment locally yeah I'll just throw
out a quick anecdote you reminded me of
talking to another colonel who had
worked building Afghan security forces
he he had worked at the core level so
one of the senior operational commands
in Afghanistan in the West and talking
to the chief of staff for that Corps who
was the principal guy he advised
whenever the the actual commander was
away and the chief of staff was sort of
having to make decisions he had to be
extraordinarily cognizant of these
dynamics and he would say I can't even
fire because he was not Pashto and he's
like I can't fire a Pashtun captain
right even if he's a complete scumbag
because of this dynamic and not that he
know actually couldn't but there would
be consequences and so he had to wait
for the boss to get back and brief the
boss and the boss who was posh tuned
could sort of crack down on on this guy
but that's you know that was a few years
ago but that's the kind of stuff that I
think Randy is talking to and I'm
concerned about is going forward
particularly as the American presence
goes away which it will at some point
2014-2018 2070 at some point it's going
away that's that's the kind of stuff I
worry about we have a lot of people i
meeting not about guessing you've got a
lot of people waiting well I just want
to
yeah the next person in line but if you
have a comment the only comment I was
make is you know you need to focus on
the the macro-level and not look at you
know what's happening at this village or
that village of questions as you go
forward are you doing anything that's
achieving a realizable overall objective
that serves American purposes and not
simply focus on you know
because of some he doesn't get
treated like we were just sort of you
know view this with the lens of history
30 years out from now and really view
this from a macro macro level is this
not real a distraction a side bump of
Rochelle that is ultimately taking away
our to focus on the real problem and I'm
going to argue that watch their attire
but for the reasons that we can discuss
it for a bottle of water coolant this
far more menacing ever aspired eight and
when I heard the timeline is sending
2014 I recently got it that we're gonna
defer to 2014 trying to find some space
for components to deal with long overdue
sory some beauty the second sideshow
it's really kept us from
I mean we clearly you know sort of
saying from the same hem book though
knowing the two of us it would be more
like a dirty Limerick but anyway yeah I
do think it is I mean the fundamental
thing was September 10th 2001 nobody in
this country cared about Afghanistan
it's it's it's a strategic backwater
that was not an accident that was not an
oversight it's a fundamental fact right
Pakistan is vastly more important Iran
is vastly more important Afghanistan it
doesn't matter who runs I've gone ass on
the Taliban want their little slice of
heaven or whatever you want to call it
and they're going to be quiescent with
that the real concern is transnational
jihadism and nuclear proliferation and
the question then is how do you go about
making Afghanistan not a rear area
abe's right that the 9/11 hijackers were
not trained there but there was some
planning that took place at our neck
farms in place like that so the question
is how do you prevent that from
happening in the future I think that is
I don't want to say trivially easy but
it's extraordinarily easy right it you
look at the campaign that's going on
inside Pakistan it's not going to defeat
al-qaeda but it's certainly been
disruptive right I don't think anyone
would argue that and it requires no
ground troops right look at Yemen we've
conducted attacks there for the past
nine years with no ground troops Somalia
no ground troops
you're telling me with it with 15,000
10,000 ground troops focused only on al
Qaeda you can't make it the most
inhospitable place to al Qaeda in the
world nonsense right is utter nonsense
people say you can't get the
intelligence nonsense so that's that's
what I think the United States should do
is focus on a much smaller more discreet
mission the Taliban will run half the
country easily but we can keep them from
running the other half upon Sherri
Tajiks will fight the Taliban harder
than we ever would as long as they have
two bullets and one gun so it's
trivially easy to keep them from running
half the country and the other half it's
not going to be a nice place for Afghans
but we're talking about us
security interests let me add one more
comment since you opened at the
macro-level I a hundred and fifty
percent to agree with you if you look
back with a thirty-year historic lenses
we actually capable doing it Vietnam
we're gonna be exactly where you suggest
we're gonna looking at it as a sort of
minor bump and sideshow that costs us
fifty to a hundred billion dollars in a
bunch of lives and has no greater impact
they'll great impact on the you know the
great strategic balance here what Austin
is also saying and I think you're
suggesting is the current events in
Pakistan are a much more serious concern
and I share with you the concerns here
and that's really where we need to you
know put our efforts I mean if you want
to spend you know people suggested as
one of my colleagues at you know getting
on an airplane and leading or sort of
not going to do that right now for
better for worse if you want to you know
continue on as Austin has suggested and
our colleagues do got lived in the piece
a couple of months ago in in the times
you know using things like predator
strikes which are you know very low cost
they can be operated by guy sitting in
Virginia Nevada and they comfort of
their own air-conditioned whatever at
limited cost in no lives and some modest
collateral damage fine help yourself but
it's not going to solve any great
geopolitical problem okay I want to do I
think George doesn't alternate I just
and it gets back to a little bit because
we we throw up these alternatives first
of all looking at hindsight I mean we're
in Afghanistan right now so really the
best I think we should really focus on
R&D on whether or not whether or not I
mean arguing at this point whether or
not it was a mistake or not I mean I
really it's figuring out how to how to
move forward I think is is best and I
think the problem was throwing when
people use counterinsurgency and
counterterrorism is what I'm really
talking about right now is we do need a
comprehensive approach and I think
that's what we need to look at to even
get it what we're talking about in
Afghanistan and starting to withdraw and
do certain
certain conditions are gonna have to be
there on the ground in my opinion from
what I what I saw in my area the the CDI
the initiatives that Austin was talking
about they will not survive out there in
those areas unless there's some kind of
a political accommodation and we won't
get the kind of intelligence and sure we
can blanket the whole area with all
other kinds of assets but we're not
going to have people telling us that
there's terrorists out there or their
safe havens unless we have allies out
there and we're gonna have to work to do
that and that's gonna be part of I think
reconciliation or or some sort of
political accommodation so I think that
we have to look for I guess what I'm
getting at is that we have to figure out
the way forward from this if we're going
to get down to a certain piece and I
certainly believe that a stable
Afghanistan will help with what's going
on in Pakistan and which is is what you
were you were bringing up and I guess
that's that's that's the argument here
is is just staying and doing very little
first of all how do we get to that point
and then is it worthwhile stabilizing
that so it will also help Pakistan and I
believe that it will I'll jump in
respond to that I don't want to spend
too much time on this because there are
four other people in line but first on
intelligence you know I think you're
right to get intelligence on the very
local Taliban does require a pretty
significant presence we're talking about
a few hundred non-local ie Arab who's
back
Chechen Weger whatever guys that don't
necessarily blend in and we're able to
find them with no ground troops and even
until recently no Pakistani ground
troops in Fattah right this is why I
think this intelligence problem while
real is not is not as insurmountable ism
as some folks want to frame it - I think
you're right CDI sort of or local
defense thrown out willy-nilly across
the province is you know you're setting
those guys up for being overrun what you
have to do is place them in key areas
where they're going to be logistically
supportable and where there will be
local allies and I think you can find
those places now it may only be in the
north right it may only be your pawn
shoes
but I was in you know pond cheer you
know not so very long ago and with no
you know US Special Forces there it's
pretty safe why because it's all timings
right you can find places to hold even
if you concede the entire posh tune
population of Afghanistan which is a
plurality not a majority to the Taliban
you're still going to hold you know you
picked a number forty percent of the
country fifteen sixty and from there you
can operate to do the kind of missions
against al-qaida in other words the
people that attacked us that will be
possible so I agree that it cannot be
done overnight you're absolutely right
we can't just snap our fingers and be at
this posture but I think the the
question is going forward do we commit
more and more resources or try and get
on a much quicker glide path down to
this level I I fundamentally agree with
you though this is not something that
can happen by next summer because in the
real issue Dinis how long do we keep
that footprint doing counterterrorism
and for how long because you're not
really solving the problem you can have
to keep that there for what you're
talking that's really the questions we
need that it certainly might be but the
question is do you commit more and more
resources into something that you know
as I said I'm not very sanguine about it
doesn't solve your al-qaeda problem
where do you try and get down to the
minimal level that we're at in Pakistan
as quickly as possible
let me add finish this with one miner
coming you you're going to withdraw and
you're going to leave at some point in
time and when you leave there are some
people that are simply going to get
clobbered there is no way around it it
happened in Vietnam and it happened
every well so we've ever gone you're
just going to have to understand that's
the nature of the universe when you
depart there are some groups that are
simply not going to survive and you
can't stay there forever putting in
resources on the hopes that you're going
to get over this hump and they'll all
live happily ever after
let me try and give you a quick answer
to this one apart from the security work
here so in a couple of years over
working in the drug czars office and
managed to ultimately marry one of the
leading drug researchers in the world so
I've learned a little friend sort of
both sides of the equation
I mean their thing that the business
really is demand driven and everybody
including the Latin Americans others
told us so long as you've got this great
demand the supply will be there
it really is demand driven and there's
not much you can do about that
a couple of years ago the drugs are very
McCaffrey sitting at dinner at our house
telling me why he's gonna spend all this
money and he's gonna change the nature
of the economy in Colombia that didn't
gonna happen and no matter what you do
unless you're going to change the demand
in this country Europe and everywhere
else you're not gonna really radically
change the demand for illicit drugs
which is why in my earlier comments a if
you look ten years down the road you're
still gonna have these crops they're
they're meeting a demand and they're
doing it in the most cost-effective way
I mean seventy percent of the cocaine in
this world comes from one place the ARPA
halakhah Valley why simply because it's
the most efficient place of the world to
grow the place grow this stuff and
that's what goes on why do you get most
your heroin out of there because it's
their major crop and it is probably the
most efficient place to do it things
aren't going to change I do want to
throw out two real quick points one if
you look at the Taliban's rise to power
they were they took a pretty hands-off
approach to to opium until they had
already consolidated power I think this
might tell us something about the
prioritization of counterinsurgency
versus counter narcotics to the extent
and narcotics actually fund the
insurgency I'll take a somewhat
cold-blooded view and say it doesn't
matter that opium has grown it matters
where the money from the opium goes if
it goes into occupied while a Karzai's
pockets allegedly or to any other folks
that's fine as long as it doesn't go to
the Taliban so the issue then is to make
sure that people that are at least
neutral towards the United States
dominate the drug trade I realize I can
say that because I am NOT in government
and I may be rapidly you know decreasing
my chances to be in government but
that's fine because I think that's the
honest they they just not pass the
polygraph if you associate with me or
just
I blew those chains already away we only
have a few minutes left so could I ask
the three people to all give their
questions and have the three panelists
respond to all three sets of questions
at once so that we can pack everything
in George's party's most important needs
with quality I wonder if our ability to
do that is limited by our time you know
this is our pursuit of quantity
basically the best we can do different
the second is you know I'm thinking
about what when Austin is saying about
you know political dynamics are really
what matters well I guess I wonder you
know where does that put it in terms of
thinking about a US policies suggestion
for improving the police is there a
generalizable message or is it just you
know we have to train our people better
there's that longer in country how do we
think about improving the overall
quality and effectiveness
Afghan security force Thanks first of
all dr. vets stress in general she's
saying of all good question that
addresses the public security it's a
short-term question I think from look at
continuing from say finding season in
2009 to find the upcoming season what
what we've seen we want to see is a
transition from sort of an alliance war
to really award that's pretty clearly
dominated by American forces what what
do you guys see is the impact of that
one on the ground in terms of creating
that space to the degree the sentries
are talking about 2014 and beyond and to
in terms of affecting our society's
ability to sustain
puggy of these two things corresponding
that's a second question is very
different about the threat to Shara
what kind of evidence we have actually
let's have final comments and reverse
burger babe well you've raised a couple
of of important things and one is tying
the work of the NGOs and the others to a
counterinsurgency strategy you know at a
micro level and I descend there for a
couple of seconds the NGOs that have
been funded I think by and large have
been doing a phenomenal job in
particular areas in education and so
forth and you know to the extent we can
extend funding on that it's to the
benefit of the country it's not going to
change the overall strategy or where
it's going to get I mean you raise the
the hearts and minds terms and
unfortunately ambassador comer the
architect of Vietnamization who sort of
coined this if you you know don't get
with it you know and we're going to sort
of burn your village down blowtorch Bob
isn't around and you really can't make
that tie and it's not not going to
happen and that you know no matter how
much you do and how well we fund the
NGOs and Lord bless them they're raising
this 28 percent illiteracy to something
greater they're not going to get at that
much closer to 100 or change the entire
nature of the geopolitical situation in
any near or medium term and you really
can't tie it to the counterinsurgency
strategy and I'll stop there a bunch of
good questions in in reverse order
really quickly how do we know qst still
exists you can go to Plata go to certain
hotels go to certain neighborhoods you
can you can find them
the real question of which i think is
what was the subtext was what is their
actual relationship to facts on the
ground in Afghanistan and I think that
is a little murkier the Taliban is not
as everybody has noted a sort of you
know unified force in any means so it's
an open question to me you know what
would happen if if negotiations with
like you know the sort of QST writ large
happens in terms of facts on the ground
I think it would be significant but
maybe not
point to Colonel George made as a myth
as significant is as we hope development
in point I think are intimately related
I understand the NGOs annoyance at being
included but particularly for the u.s.
perspective this is who we rely on to do
things right ambassador Khalilzad you
know mentioned US IDs truncation after
Vietnam they they can't do any of this
themselves they have to rely on what
they call implementing partners many of
them are NGOs some are not some are you
know the emerging development industrial
complex but that's who has to do it so I
think they're going to be implicated one
way or another I understand their
frustration but it is what it is on the
on the security bubble the transition
from Alliance war to the u.s. war on I
think this actually you know to your
second point is more important this is
this is going to become a primarily US
war very soon even our even our sort of
toughest mates are starting to bail out
on us the Canadians had a hard fight in
Kandahar beginning in 2006 they're
throwing in the towel in the next year I
think we have the the troops to do this
but it will mean more and more burden it
will also mean we will lose some of the
insight that they have worked so hard to
build up over the past five years now
they are willing to send folks one of my
good friends is going to work with Todd
in Kandahar over the next year who's
Canadian has been there since 2006 but I
think that's where we'll really lose
some some capabilities is the insight
that they've worked up over time
hopefully we can hand that off but it's
it's very hard to pass insight from US
unit to US unit when a rotation takes
place it's even harder I think to pass
it multinational quantity versus quality
I think I think Randy's right it is the
quality that matters when I think in
many cases would rather have 25,000
really committed well-trained troops
than 250,000 guys that run away as soon
as the gunfire starts but in steel the
weapons yeah I didn't steal the weapons
and sell the bullets and all of that
good stuff but it it is tough to build
quality quickly I mean anybody in the
Special Operations community
sort of tell you that is a truth that
right you can't manufacture quality
overnight we probably can do better but
it's it's going to be tough on the
police at the local level this is an
insurmountable problem absent political
change the cops I dealt with and
khakhras this past summer you know we
would go into a village and we would see
the cops there the SF guys would be like
were they doing here they must just be
like bum and some food off these people
because they are never here right
because that's not what they're about so
political change has to precede I think
any improvement in the quality of local
police now there are plans to do things
like transition in the elite and copped
Afghan national civil war police on a
temporary level while you can retrain
these guys but my point is it's not a
retraining problem it's a political
problem if everybody's from the Popples
eye tribe it's a no-brainer that there's
going to be some issues going forward
yeah I just touch I think we've kind of
beat the as far as the quality versus
the quantity and it really is it's gonna
be different region to region where you
have where you have political buy-in in
certain areas and you could really focus
on quality because you've got the right
mix so it's just like Afghanistan a very
decentralized problem I think that
that's how you're gonna have to tackle
it I would be encouraged by what's
happening at the national level as far
as building up other aspects of enablers
which is a lot of the other things that
we're talking about that we would need
to continue to prosecute any kind of
action against terrorists in the future
I think the quite Ashura
question was was already answered and
the only thing I would add again is
there several other groups that are over
there that we sometimes we lose focus
and we just get primarily focused on
that one group but as political
accommodation reconciliation and all
these are going to take place you're
gonna have to look at a lot of different
groups over there moving forward you
know it's on the development one because
we didn't talk about that much is you
know a lot of people see Afghanistan as
I've seen it as a reconstruction problem
and that's kind of got to give us a lot
of problems today that we looked at it
that way for several years and a lot of
our money is really contributed to the
problem
so when people a lot of these groups
that come over are spending US
government money and I think we have we
owe it to taxpayers to make sure that
we're spending that money correctly
we're making sure that we're integrated
and how we're doing development over
there and it is important that we we
look at that sometimes I think we get
caught up in to more because we have a
lot of resources that's we get caught up
in the metric of how much we spend makes
us feel good and it's not and I think
that has heard us and and we have
actually contributed to corruption and
we just need to really focus on on that
in the future Alliance were the question
I think the obviously the cost will
increase for us public opinion
everything that's already going on right
now what I do think we should be doing
is working harder to get regional
stakeholders involved I mean the
question came up about drugs one country
that has that is very focused on that is
Russia and what I would like I think we
should do is spend a lot more energy
trying to get a lot of more of the
regional stakeholders involved in and
what's going on over there and instead
of sometimes the focus which seems to be
you know very centric to us or
Eurocentric and and put a little more
energy diplomatically in getting those
stakeholders involved and I think that
would help so and I guess last is like I
said it did it is popular to point out
the 28 percent literacy rate or five
percent literacy rate and and all the
problems that we know exist over there
what what is what I really I think is
important is whatever strategy it is and
counter-insurgency or CT throws are not
just strategies and then we have to have
comprehensive idea on how to move
forward here what kind of government is
going to work best or if we're not going
to leave it how are we going to leave
those things that we really focus on
energy I'm figuring out some solutions
to those kinds of problems in line with
what we think our president and our
elected leaders decide is the
our policies thank you all